[Music]
the vaccines are coming
that's the reassuring message from
leaders across latin america
this from the chilean president after
meeting regional heads of state in
santiago
to discuss ensuring comprehensive
vaccination coverage
that no one is left out
[Applause]
this will allow us to better control the
coronavirus pandemic
and which also allows us to recover our
freedoms and
recover the capacity of all people to
fulfill and to take forward
their dreams and projects mexico is the
fourth country in the world to approve
the use of the pfizer vaccine
it comes as the number of infections and
deaths in mexico continue to rise
more than 11 000 new daily infections
mexico city has declared a covered
emergency
i trust to the residents of this city we
are on alert because of covert 19.
hospitalizations are on the rise and
only
only if we all comply will we be able to
reduce contagions in the city
a similar grim picture is reported
across the region
more than 90 percent of intensive care
beds in the brazilian cities of rio de
janeiro and curitiba
are occupied
the population needs to do its part as
tight as we might be
it is important to say that our health
professionals are exhausted
after all these months in this war
against the coronavirus
in this battle for life and with latin
american economies being hit hard by the
pandemic
christmas this year is unlikely to bring
much respite
i'm not going to buy anything because i
can't i'm unemployed and receiving the
government's aid
it's peanuts and i can't do much with it
so there will be no gifts
no christmas
we'll spend less because the future is
so unclear it's not easy
what we really want is that the covert
vaccine arrives as soon as possible
the vaccines are that light at the end
of a long tunnel
but it will take time to see their
effects and precautions still need to be
taken
that's proving a difficult message to
drum home
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires